for those of you keeping score at home
last week was one for the reuben report
record books our week started off by
interviewing senator john mccain a war
hero one of the longest serving members
of congress and a republican nominee for
president of the united states senator
mccain and i had a frank discussion on
this year's election money in politics
and foreign policy what struck me more
than anything while talking to the
senator was whether you agree or
disagree with his political opinions
it's clear that he's really trying to
bridge the ideological divide and do
what he feels is right for the country
the entire time i was talking to him i
kept thinking what a better candidate
senator mccain would be than any of the
current contenders in the gop rat race
immediately after interviewing senator
mccain i had the chance to interview
lubna ahmed lubna is a 23 year old
engineering student and an atheist
fighting for secular values in her
homeland of iraq simply by talking to me
about secularism from the confines of
her closed society she instantly became
braver than pretty much every person
that i know i'm honored that she chose
me as the first public person to talk to
and i'll always be an ally for her
whether she's in iraq or wherever life
takes her while i was in awe of her
during the interview the most impactful
part to me was when we talked about some
of the people that we both admire
including sam harris and richard dawkins
this portion of our chat illuminated
exactly what this show is about ideas
the same ideas that sam and richard
sparked in me a 39 year old guy born in
brooklyn living in los angeles also were
sparked in lubna a 23 year old atheist
in iraq this shows you the true power of
ideas good or bad ideas can transcend
nationality race or religion
my final interview last week was with
the former leader of the english defense
league and now outspoken
anti-immigration activist tommy robinson
as i mentioned at the top of the show
last week i was hesitant to even talk to
tommy because people might call me a
bigot or a racist not only am i glad
that we did the interview but i'm really
proud of your reaction to it whether on
youtube twitter or facebook you guys all
kept the conversation going after tommy
and i put it down it was complete and
total confirmation of last week's direct
message being afraid to talk can no
longer be part of the equation i have no
doubt there is a real movement happening
right now people are absolutely sick of
being divided conversation is the key to
bringing us together and that's why in
one week i talked to a man who was
almost the leader of the free world a
woman who puts her life on the line to
say what she believes and another man
who's on a crusade of his own
it's totally irrelevant whether i agree
with everything my guests say the
important thing is to not be afraid to
hear them as the internet brings us all
closer together we find ourselves
connected with people in a way that we
could have only dreamt of a couple years
ago despite that connection i still get
messages from viewers explaining that
sometimes you guys are afraid to say
certain things to your friends in real
life or to post certain articles on
facebook for all to see
if lubna a 23 year old in iraq isn't
afraid to speak up then you guys can't
be either there's no time for silence
anymore
yeah there are genuinely bad people in
the world and sometimes talking to them
won't get you the results you want
however you have to be brave enough to
have the conversation in the first place
don't let louder voices with worse
intentions drown you out
all right according to wikipedia my
guest this week is either the former
king of mesopotamia or a youtuber not
afraid to speak his mind on
controversial topics that's right i have
carl benjamin better known as sargon of
akkad on the show carl sargon what do i
call you
whichever you want i get called both all
day long so whichever one you're
comfortable with honestly sargon has
sort of overtaken carl there's sort of a
batman bruce wayne situation here right
you know there kind of is actually yeah
it's it's my the the name sargon has
definitely um traveled before me in many
places where
um progressives uh tend to congregate
you said progressives i'm shocked that
you didn't say regressives
but we'll get to that momentarily
so uh before we get into all the the
deep stuff and and the topics and the
meat of this i want people to get to
know you a little bit because i think
it's sort of just recently that you're
showing your face more you're out there
more your name's getting out there a
little bit more so how did carl benjamin
become sargon of akkad
um oh that's a that's an interesting uh
that's an interesting story it's not
actually that interesting at all now say
that um
well just make it interesting how about
that i'll try i'll try and i'll try and
fabricate something um no basically
about about two and a half years ago i
you know you you know when you're on the
internet you end up um just choosing a
moniker that you sign into places with
and i i just happen to like the
historical figure of sagan and mccann he
was an interesting figure i like the
sound of the name and you know so i was
just using that and i had signed up to
youtube um in 2010 just to upload some
videos of myself with an ancient sling
you know the sort of uh i you know made
one according to historical sort of
documents and i tested it out and it's
that you can see why they're dangerous
weapons sort of thing and then a few
years later i
was basically getting really really
worried about the
the sort of political climate in the
left i was starting to see more and more
often
um
just my own principles being completely
violated and and it was really really
really worrying and it was the sort of
thing that was genuinely starting to
ignore me because i mean i would see
people arguing for arguing against
people's freedom of speech or they would
be arguing against um the meritocratic
system or something like that and
everyone would seem to be going along
with it this this was it you know there
were so many people going yeah that's
exactly how we should do things and i
started panic thinking
christ i totally disagree in fact i
disagree on such a fundamental level i
have to say something and so i found
myself just motivated sort of
right uh just like under five minute
scripts or something and then read them
with a very very bad microphone
then i mean it's all about the mic
it really is it's it's a it's a
magician's trick almost i had just the
cheaper microphone it was really really
terrible quality and i'd read these
ideas and they started gaining um some
views and stuff people started
subscribing to my channel and stuff and
looking back now i'm thinking god they
were really there was a lot of
forbearance there about my technical
skills and what i was saying but i guess
some people agreed with what i was
saying because now i've got um i've just
passed a quarter of a million
subscribers yeah and uh yeah and now i i
do this full time and it's uh it's a
wonderful thing to be doing is fighting
for my principles
so i love that i love that because as i
say on the show every week what i'm
trying to do here is make this about
ideas and that's really what you were
talking about you were hearing bad ideas
and then you wanted to beat them with
better ideas and clearly it's working
because you got over 250 000 subscribers
and and when i had my personal awakening
because everyone knows at this point you
know i've always considered myself
liberal then i was in the progressive
world which i now see as some sort of
mental disorder um but when i was having
my awakening out of that
uh everyone online said to me you've got
to talk to sargon
uh so my so my first question to you
before we get into the the heavy stuff
is did you study politics what what
brought you into the political realm i i
didn't it was um
it was just watching the news i guess
and just watching you know popular i
mean i used to be i used to be a big fan
of the young turks um i used to consider
myself progressive until i met
progressives and like you said i i
couldn't believe the things they were
saying it it really struck me as some
sort of mental disorder
why would they start saying things like
this and yeah and then i then i i i
found myself sort of floundering on my
own because i you know there's i i'm not
a conservative i can't
i can't bring myself to subscribe to
conservative ideas they just don't they
don't work for me i don't i don't
believe in them um and so i was
basically on my own you know everyone i
knew was who was a liberal was quite
happy to ignore the foundational
principles of liberalism in order to
in order to push progressivism further
and the more i've the more i've learned
about progressivism the more i realize
it's really used liberalism as a trojan
horse
to you know they've said oh we're
liberals we're progressives and
i mean on the on the surface of it
they're not necessarily arguing for
different things it's it's really the
methods the the problem it's not
necessarily the goals um but yeah they
they happily use the the terms
interchangeably and they are not
interchangeable at all yeah so let's
let's unpack that a little bit so i've
heard you say that you refer to yourself
as a classic liberal and the more that
i've been doing this i mean that's
really where i feel at home too i think
now i have some really strong
libertarian leanings also but there's
there's some there's some play there
there's some uh common ground there but
what does classic liberalism mean to you
um well it's just the
it's just the basic enlightenment values
that came out of the alignment the you
know civil liberties political freedom
freedom expression freedom of
association
economic freedom representative
democracy the rule of law it's all these
just there is no argument against these
ideas these are great ideas they're
universal ideas you know everyone is
protected under these ideas unlike with
progressivism where the first thing they
will do is demarcate a group they will
say right women black people gay people
these people need special treatment and
that special treatment will involve the
infringement of your personal rights and
that is where i have a problem because
if we all ascribe to the same rights a
we're all being treated as equals b
nobody ends up losing their rights and i
don't have a point c but i wish i did
i think i've covered it all the reasons
yeah that was pretty good so this is
sort of uh an example of the road to
hell is paved with good intentions right
because this is where i've seen i know a
lot of progressives uh a lot of them
won't talk to me anymore people that i
that were my good friends only you know
six eight months ago that won't talk to
me anymore but i believe that for the
most part and we're gonna get into some
of the really dangerous ones but i think
for the most part people that consider
themselves progressive most of the
people that are going to bernie sanders
rallies i think are good people i think
their intentions are correct so we're
really talking about the methodology
here right
yeah there
there are a few
the the problem is you have a
a bunch of
you have a bunch of motivating factors
that kind of coalesce
and in mixed in with that you have the
more sort of
uh pernicious aspects of people who can
see
where this is going because a lot of it
involves giving the benefit of the doubt
to people who
you would otherwise necessarily be
skeptical to people making i mean for
example rape laws um one of the big
progressive pushes and
is is to
have it so the victim quote unquote the
the alleged victim is believed and
therefore the burden of proof becomes
laid on the person who's being accused
rather than on the accuser and they do
this by the use of statistics they say
oh well you know i can't know what the
number is but something like i know five
percent of accused rapists go to jail or
something like that and therefore they
assume that there is a massive problem
with the system that 95 percent of
accused rapists are also actual rapists
and therefore just being let off through
a bad system
but the thing is a we don't know that we
have no idea how many of the people who
are accused are actually
illegitimate rapists and deserve to be
condemned for it and convicted for it
but secondly what we're doing there is
reversing the system because at the
moment what we have is a system that
isn't perfect but can deliver justice in
a reliable way you know the we we can be
quite sure that the people going to jail
probably aren't innocent you know we've
been through a rigorous rigorous trial
the burden of proof is on the accuser
they've managed to prove beyond
reasonable doubt and you know that's
fine because that way you're going to
get the minimum number of people who
didn't do anything wrong being punished
as if they did something wrong whereas
to flip the script on that would mean
that you now have a system that is
inherently unjust that might be able to
deliver justice on occasion the occasion
being the person being accused is on
camera somewhere else at the time that
they're supposed to have been doing the
rape or something like that you know
right
it's it's that sort of thing it's it
would be incidental justice you know you
couldn't rely on it because you don't
presume the innocence of the people
being accused the guilt is being
presumed and it's being done like you
say out of good motives the idea that
you know we don't want to call the
victims liars it's like no i don't want
to call the victim a liar either but
it's one of those points where you're on
the horns of a dilemma and you have no
choice but to take a responsible course
of action for the safety of someone who
hasn't done anything wrong right so all
right so there's a lot there that i
wanna
i knew that that's how this conversation
was going to go because there's so much
to talk about and these things are
always inextricably linked that's what
i've found uh whenever i'm talking about
anything related to sort of regressive
ideology and then when you start talking
about feminism and islamism and all
these things uh they're they're all so
inextricably inextricably linked um
so
let's let's jump into gamergate for a
second and then we'll get back to some
of that stuff because gamergate i think
is one of the things that really sort of
put you on the map and even by
saying the word gamergate i've made
people crazy we know this now i've
discussed it with a couple people i've
had milo yiannopoulos on i've talked
about it with christina hoff summers but
you yourself you are a true gamer
correct
yes i am indeed a true gamer what are
you playing these days uh i play a game
called ark survival evolved most um i
actually have my own server where i pay
for a server where i get to run around
killing virtual dinosaurs it's great wow
well uh thank you for taking a moment
from slaying dinosaurs to uh to join me
here
um but yeah you've really been in the
gamergate thing and i think you're
considered sort of an expert on it so
can you give me like a two three minute
explanation of what gamergate is and i
know that's almost impossible because it
seems like it's something different to
everybody
uh it is i can give you my version of
what it is but like you say it is
different to everybody and you're going
to get people who are going to say
that's not what gamergate is and what
not so um
for me it is
it's a very definite reaction to
regressives
infiltrating the video game media now it
this is something that we saw we saw
happening over the course about five
years where they were just incriminal
just
larger and larger numbers of them would
be hired at various gaming publications
and then they would start writing
articles like are these video games
sexist why are these video games
misogynist there are no trans people in
these video games this is racist this is
you know the the
standard regressive lies yeah 101. yeah
and they would be promoting very famous
feminists like anita sarkeesian or zoe
quinn people with and i i don't i don't
know i don't want to sound mean but
very few real credentials in the video
game industry i mean like zoe quinn want
the the uh franz ferdinand of gamergate
uh she made a a free um
did you did you ever have those uh
choose your own adventure books i love
choose your own adventure i probably had
every one of them right yeah and yeah
basically that's what she had made she
had made a digital chooser an adventure
book it was all all text no no
nothing else in it it can't have taken
very long but it was about learning to
deal with depression and i've never had
depression so i can't judge the game on
that merit so i'm on that i'm sure it's
very good but your average gamer this
wasn't really a game there wasn't a fail
state you know it wasn't there wasn't
really anything you could play it was
more like an interactive novel which is
again it's in itself's fine
but the gaming press because she was a
prominent feminist and regressive she
got unbelievable amounts of coverage and
i mean when i say unbelievable i mean
any amount of coverage for this yeah is
more than you would expect and so people
kind of they were getting sick of the
agenda being pushed on them and it's the
same with the needs sarkeesian when
anita sarkeesian did her kickstarter it
was everywhere everyone knew about it
and yet
everyone also knew that the arguments
she was presenting were
half-truths they were cherry-picked they
were she was finding individual examples
that didn't really represent the gaming
industry or any even you know
sub-sections of the gaming industry and
presenting them as if they were a
categoric statement on the condition of
the entire gaming industry and so
everyone was really kind of annoyed by
this point especially as
the way that these people work is by
riling up your emotions so almost
everything they say is fundamentally
accusatory they would say things like
you're a sexist you're a racist if you
like these games there aren't enough you
know black people in this game not
enough women in this game not gay people
all this sort of thing and if you're
enjoying it you're a bad person
whereas most pop people are thinking
well just hell just just make the games
you want to make right
but no that's not what these people are
interested in whatsoever um and so it
got to the point where
zoe quinn was caught having an affair
with
her boss
who was involved in video games and also
a journalist called nathan grayson and
the video game industries press has
always been corrupt i mean it's always
been crumbs it's come out of a hobby
press it's always been really really bad
um but this is when you say corrupt just
to pause for one sec when you say
corrupt i mean things like you know
people paying off the magazine writers
so that they'd get better reviews on the
game so they'd sell more games i mean
real corrupt stuff yeah yeah and a lot a
lot of it's in your face as well do you
go to a video game uh so online magazine
and the backdrop would be the
advertisement for a game that then would
be reviewed in the center column you
know
it's not you know it's not even they're
not trying to hide it but for the most
part nobody really cared because they
weren't being preachy about you know
they were trying to sell you video games
and that's what people were there for
and therefore nobody was really that
bothered
but then the regressives turned up and
started being corrupt in a whole
different way instead of instead of
being motivated by money which i suppose
is to their credit they were motivated
by ideology and so now they would hire
people into positions and promote things
that were
all based on cronyism it was all their
friends and family members and whatnot
they would they would push everything to
do with their agenda and people
realistically people have just been
really really sick against but they were
tired of this phone moralism tired of
being told that they were bad people
even though you didn't obviously none of
these people are actually bad people you
know nobody knows who all these people
are and yeah they're being they're being
pre-judged before anything happens and
it got to the point where people like
look no enough you know this has got to
stop and
that's what what that was basically it
was called the conspiracy to start with
and then the video game press instead of
turning around and saying something like
okay fair enough we haven't been doing
our due diligence you know we a lot of
them are professional trained
journalists like stephen tottillo from
kotaku he has a master's degree in
journalism and he's there saying well do
we have to be objective what's the need
for objective journalism and it and so
you can instantly see the problems that
were inherent in the video game industry
yeah and i know we can we can really go
down the rabbit hole yes we could spend
three hours with this but i think that's
i think that's a nice little beginning
piece of it but what i really find
fascinating about it and why i've
brought it up several times is because
the same things that you're talking
about how the regressives sort of
infiltrated this and turned something
that had nothing to do with sexism
or
of racism or any of these things they
made it about that and i think when i
was on your show i was saying how you
know i used to be a huge gamer i'm not
that much anymore but i like the
community and i do play some games here
and there um but like you know i played
grand theft auto and yeah you could
steal a car and punch a hooker and
people would say well that's against
women but you could also punch a man so
should they only have it that you'd only
punch men i mean even the logic behind
it doesn't really stand to to critique
and there there's no winning either it's
so this is the point
it's all what was called a kafka trap
it's either you are this thing or you're
this thing you don't even realize it you
know and there's no falsifiability to
any of their hypotheses but the the main
problem i mean if you think about it
like with grand theft auto so like what
the options not include women in the
game no way they'd they'd freak out if
you couldn't put women in the game right
or you can have the women not being able
to be treated like men again they'd be
freaking out that's not equal at all so
what i mean what are you gonna have
you're gonna have women so they just
can't be damaged or you know you you
they will not allow you to treat women
like men you know you can't beat up
women you can't but you can beat up men
and so you're you're in this position
whether you've got no win you know
there's no good answer and that's how
they want it they want you dancing to
their tune yeah
and that's what that's what's so
fascinating about this and why i think
it's so related to the political
situation with the regressives and i
also think that's why gamergate blew up
the way it did because
gamers generally are going to skew a
little younger than the people that are
solely interested in politics so because
of that i think it was this group of
people who had never been used to being
attacked or silenced before and they
were young and they were online and they
were ready to coalesce around something
and i think that's what
made it so so magical or something you
know gamers game has actually long been
the demon in the uh
in the bedroom uh for leno for like the
american christians in the late 90s
early 2000s there was i mean hillary
clinton and uh joe lieberman actually
brought legislation to try and uh try
and sort of censor video games so this
is another reason i would never vote for
hillary i mean i don't think anyone ever
should she's
a corporate shill don't vote for hillary
yeah um but she i mean there are so many
reasons not to basically
we can get into that too yeah
gamers are actually quite familiar with
being attacked politically because of
their hobby even though there hasn't
been a single study that's ever really
conclusively proven anything about video
games in fact there are dozens that say
well there's no connection between video
games and anything you know and if you
look at the statistics the rise of video
games has coincided with the dissent of
violence so i mean i'm not saying
they're connected but it's one of those
things that there is literally nothing
to show that video games are doing
anything wrong in fact there's quite a
lot to show they're doing a lot of
things yeah well i remember that i think
maybe it was around 91 or 92 when joe
lieberman was leading that that fight
against video games i think it was
because of mortal kombat i was playing
it on sega genesis at the time and i
would come home from school and play
that for hours with my friends i never
ripped anyone's skull out with their
spine attached to it you know what i
mean
not once no i tried once but i yeah i
never successfully did it so that says
something actually i think you can prove
that it probably helps people in a more
healthy way than some of their anger and
frustration don't you think oh i think
they're multiplayer games aren't they
you know they get they get groups of
guys to hang out and do something that's
not dangerous or violent you know and
think about i mean when i was a kid if
we weren't playing video games we were
on the streets
you know right it was better for us to
be at home playing video games than to
not be playing video games so uh i i
honestly can't see where the objections
come from you know but it was it's the
same with anything like dungeons and
dragons in the 80s or music in the 70s
you know video games in the 90s and the
2000s there is always something that the
you know pearl clutching moral majority
also they would like to
position themselves as has got to rail
against something and ironically that
was always the religious right you know
that was always the highly religious
authoritarian right now it is the highly
regressive
authoritarian left yeah and this is the
horseshoe theory that we talk about all
the time that the extremes on both sides
come together all right so last thought
on gamergate you know the other thing
that i think is really
nice about the community is that people
who are gamers it doesn't matter what
race you are it doesn't matter what
religion you are what sex or sexuality
any of the little dividing boxes that
the left wants to put us in it doesn't
matter what you are and that's why the
community's so strong so then when when
these people that are writing these
articles say well gamers are sexist or
gamers are racist it actually it
literally has no meaning because it's as
diverse a community as you could
possibly put out there right yeah i mean
it
you literally can't tell by playing a
video game what race or gender the
people you're playing with are because
everyone gets to choose their own avatar
they get to customize their name you
know the only way you'd know is by voice
chat you know and so for the vast
majority of people
playing video games is not tied to
identity politics and the you know
what's interesting is the um
regressive uh academics actually did pl
they spent a lot of time sort of
planning their assault on video games
and they spent a lot of time doing
research and there was an academic a
feminist academic called adrian shaw who
did a series of studies
not based on particularly large sample
sizes but large enough i would say to at
least
give you the impression that they're
going the wrong direction because her
conclusions and she was someone looking
for a way to sort of you know crack open
the video game industry with a good
reason to attack it she found that
basically uh video games didn't need
diversity video games had diversity
which meant that you know and that in
itself where where does a regressive
begin their plan of attack you know if
they think they're attacking is already
diverse you know and so basically it led
to her reframing the study she had
already conducted in a different way and
the uh the language is very
opaque
but um
basically she was not happy that
there was a plurality of markets now i
personally think a plurality of markets
is a wonderful thing i think that you
know if if you want a video if you want
video games about i don't know japanese
hentai great that's your business i'm
not interested in that i want i want
video games about killing dinosaurs
that's great that's my niche yeah
everyone gets their own niche you know
whereas the problem that they had is
that they wanted a hegemony overlap they
didn't want a plurality of markets
because then you could have diverse
markets you have markets aren't diverse
they wanted every market to be
controlled effectively by their ideology
um thankfully it's not going to happen
right so just to be clear about that so
there are people that are probably
playing mario kart that have nothing to
do with the people that are playing the
games you're playing so it doesn't make
sense even to lump all those people
together absolutely
i mean
you know there will obviously be some
crossover in every
um every game genre but
by and large you get people who have
different preferences and they play
different things it's like um
one of the things they're saying one of
the things they uh the big stat they
pull out is oh almost half of people
playing video games are women it's okay
great but what are they playing they're
not playing call of duty you know
they're not sat there on their xboxes
with their headphones in running around
calling each other gay you know
they're playing candy crush and
farmville and which all perfectly valid
forms of entertainment and more power to
them i want them to play the games they
want to play but these but by the you
know by this fact they it doesn't
justify changing anything about the
games i play because of the games they
play and vice versa is true i don't want
their games being changed to suit me
either you know that would be the last
thing i would want to impose on and so
this is
basically one of the things the
regressive left will always do is use
statistics in the most slippery way
possible you know lies damn lies and
statistics really does apply here
you i mean
they will use statistics to justify
anything so be be careful about the use
of statistics with the regressive layer
all right so you've given me a perfect
lane through gamergate to talk about
probably your other favorite thing to
talk about or at least maybe your most
controversial thing to talk about which
is feminism
uh
so let's let's go there let's talk a
little feminism uh i'm gonna give you
this in the most broad sense basically
you don't like what the feminist
movement has become is that fair to say
yes and the
one one of the dangers of talking about
feminism is that it's very often
conflated with women and this is done
exactly you're a misogynist that's the
first thing you will hear if ever you
have any complaint about feminism um
however i mean this is just obviously
logically
it's not it's not
it's nonsense feminism itself is an
ideology and you get male and female
feminists and you get people who are
male and female opposed to modern
feminism so the idea that feminism is
inherently
uh the same as women is ridiculous and
the thing is even the fewer and fewer
women every year are identifying as
feminists at the moment in america only
about 18 percent of women identify as
feminists and i think something about
nine percent of men whereas in in say
the 70s somewhere as high as 40 percent
so the feminist movement is
honestly i think i don't think he's
doing itself any favors i think it's
it's gone full regressive that's the
problem um you know i i would have no
problem calling myself a feminist if we
were in the era of say second wave
feminism we had um you know it's it's
sort of equity feminism that christina
half-summers or camille palia would be
espousing you know this this sort of
equal rights equal pay all this sort of
all the sort of things that you as any
egalitarian would be completely on board
with and would find absolutely no
objection to i find objection to but my
my problem is when we start getting into
the realms of well i mean shaming
language for a start you're a misogynist
you're this you're valuing the other
when you have any objection and quotas
or any anything like this you know and
then you then you get into the sort of
conspiracy theories patriarchy theory
you know and then it becomes
intersectional so now it involves race
and transsexuals and homosexuals and and
now it's a karaoke this is an
interlinking
uh series of oppressions and privileges
and
really you realize that what you're what
you're regurgitating is marxist rhetoric
it's all i mean if you read the
communist manifesto you understand
modern feminism you know you were
talking about the male bourgeoisie and
the female proletariat and it's the same
with black and white straight and gay
and all these sort of things and i just
don't describe to that because it
implies a shared experience that we know
men and women don't have you know
i mean and and not just men and women
like black people in here trayvon martin
did not have the same life experiences
about barack obama you know and so to
say that being black is some sort of
inherent shared oppression that they
have is ridiculous you know it just it
doesn't work and my main problem really
is is that it's become
anti-individualistic
the i mean you get famous feminists like
anita sarkeesian who will literally say
things like
um individuals women individual women's
choices don't count what matters is what
what matters is feminism or the great
you know something for the greater good
feminism something like that i can't
remember exactly how the the quote goes
but it was just one of those things
where it's just like okay i
am so totally against this that i think
i would be prepared to fight a civil war
against you you know
the these are so
anti-anti-liberal principles i can't
stand them right so so in a way it's
evolved to where it's no longer first
off women aren't a minority i think
there's something like 50 or 51 or 52
percent of the population but where
where you should be for the minority in
a minority uh what you're saying is that
they're fighting they're eliminating the
minority in the minority i think an
example of that we could use from the
american political space would be
someone like sarah palin now i don't
like the views that sarah palin espouses
at all really but can you believe that
yeah i'm not a big fan of sarah palin
that being said she's obviously a very
influential and powerful and uh
self-motivated woman so in a certain
sense she's the ultimate
uh
goal of what a feminist should be but
feminists hate her right absolutely
because she thinks wrong that's the
problem she she doesn't espouse uh she
doesn't spouse uh regressive ideologies
she doesn't i mean if she called herself
a feminist
fundamentally she wouldn't be invoking
marxist ideas she would be invoking sort
of libertarian ideas the sort of
strength of the individual hard work you
know the all these honestly i think that
you know they're not they're not bad
ideas at all but she wouldn't be in the
same camp as say gloria steinem steinem
or um bell hooks or something like that
yeah
and i i don't it's weird talking about
marxism you know it's really weird
because
i mean almost no nobody really
understands it these days but and the
only people understand it are the
academics and universities who teach it
and it is the communist manifesto is the
third most prescribed book
in universities in america just so you
know the communist manifesto communism
died everywhere but in the west it's so
bizarre
we fetishize these things right
absolutely people who live under
communism hate communism they think it's
a terrible idea they know that i mean
they they had to queue at three in the
morning for milk and eggs you know they
think it's a terrible idea but
the people in the west have never lived
through being put into practice and so
they don't understand it's you know they
don't really you know viscerally
understand the the real
true nature of it i guess and so
you know when you're sat in a
comfortable house that's been built
under a capitalistic system and you've
got lots of money you're doing very well
for yourself you're thinking well maybe
we should you know maybe maybe it's not
such a bad idea and it's it's crazy you
know and but it's it's these principles
that inform almost everything about
third wave feminism it's all about it's
all about power dynamics privileged and
oppressed privileged and oppressed which
is why i was watching the young turks
the other day in fact and uh jimmy dore
i think it was uh he he actually had his
tongue in his mouth and he was saying
that um
he
was for the oppressed in every situation
so he took the example of israel so
israel oppresses a palestinian man he's
in favor of the palestinian man and then
if the palestinian man oppresses his
wife he's in favor of the wife and it's
just like yeah but
you've you've just said you are and are
not in favor of the palestinian man
there jimmy you know that is inherently
confident you can't you can't be in
favor of the man and the wife
you know at the same time which one are
you in favor on you know it's it's that
kind of
it it's got this inherent contradiction
to it and they don't seem to want to
acknowledge that yeah and that's why as
we've said for a while now this this
regressive ideology it's always putting
narrative over fact
that's really the most when you whittle
it down to what it really is it has to
be narrative over fact so you just pick
the most depressed and then you get
everybody on the ladder and then that's
how you judge everybody which is the
reverse of judging a minority within a
minority and those are the people that
we should be for
yeah absolutely and the the crazy thing
about it as well is that
these things are inherently racist and
sexist and you know any other iss you
want to but the the the problem is that
normally when people think oh you're
being a racist you think you're being a
racist to the
i guess the the oppressed if that's what
you want to call you know the the
minority who have suffered from racial
discrimination in the past you know what
black
people tell you
are not structures or systems of power
they are principles they are ideas they
are they are they are ways of viewing
the world and so you can be racist to
white people you can be sexist to men
and vice versa and so
it's this kind of like say it's the
narrative they've gone out of the way to
redefine a bunch of words and then they
have cherry-picked data points to arrive
a nice location where they can say you
as a white man are not now allowed to
speak why because you're a white man
and they will literally turn around and
tell you that that is not racist and
sexist i think it's amazing you give
them enough credit to say they've picked
these uh data points because i i think
in most cases they haven't even gone
that far you're giving them the benefit
of the doubt
that i can no longer give them but we
started here on feminism so let's not go
too far but but that's the interesting
thing that every time i'm talking about
all this stuff we realize how the the
inter there's this interleaved theme
between gamergate between feminism all
of this stuff so uh as far as feminism i
saw an interesting video that you did
where you took the the three types of
what you said were the three types of
male feminists um and i thought it was
really interesting because i was because
i defend women i i believe women should
be equal
uh and and that's pretty much it so
anyone can define me however they want
but i thought the way you broke these
three type of men down was pretty
interesting can you do that for us
um oh god it was a while ago i did that
video i can't really remember it now um
okay so yeah
it's basically about self-interest i
think i mean you get um
you get men who are
they they want to be rewarded for doing
something heroic and protective you know
it's it's it and i i think that uh cheng
might fall into this category uh where
he's he's he's a big guy he's not he he
himself that you know this trap doesn't
have any particular
um fears in for his own physical
security and so he thinks so i'm going
to use my physical presence to protect
women because that would be a
a you know laudable thing to do and it
would be
except that they're doing it for their
own self interest they're doing it their
own
for the for their own personal feelings
um so at the end of the day this is a
guy who basically wants to get laid i
mean in a lot of respects i don't want
to put it that way but yeah it kind of
is it's it's and the thing is it's not
necessarily getting laid either i love a
lot of it is just for um
just for the sort of emotional reward
you know because like a social cred
yeah yeah and just and just um
just to get the pat on the head you know
it's it's that kind of to feel good
about themselves
but requires permission from someone
else this case being a woman and the
thing is you end up you end up getting
really sort of um
really unhealthy dynamics because you'll
find women who are looking for men to do
things for them and you will find men
who are looking to do things for women
and you will get this kind of
feedback loop where they'll reinforce
each other you know you this this this
guy stands up for this woman who is
using him to fight her battles and so
this guy ends up fighting battles aren't
his battles but are being reinforced
constantly by and again this is not like
all women in fact most women are not
like this but you will you know women
are humans too and you get bad women as
well as good women and you find that
this this is basically one of the
problems with um the progressives
because like we were saying earlier and
i hate to come back to like progressives
but feminism is just one like branch
under the umbrella of the progressive
sort of tree i guess you know it's it it
all ties together um but you like you
said you get most people they think
they're doing it for the right reasons
you know they think well i'm a good
person i need to be helping women and
minorities and gays and trans and
whatever
but the
the problem is that they they have this
kind of toolbox of rhetoric that virtue
signals to other regressives it shows
them saying hey look i'm using this kind
of language therefore i'm on your team
you can come and support me on twitter
or wherever you know and
and so you will get people who think
okay great i'm going to do that because
i want to be an activist i want to do
something good and then you'll get the
other kind of person who is the more
malicious person who will think great i
can use this to my own advantage
and they are the people you've got to be
really worried about i mean
there's in gamergate there was a woman
called randy harper she wasn't actually
part of game games she was part of the
problem but um
the the i've never seen it more starkly
represented than in her example
i think i think it was 2011 2012. she uh
she was on a bsd which is a programming
language uh podcast
and she was literally saying well i'm a
woman in tech and i don't have a problem
with this you know i think i think the
feminists are way overblowing this
problem with misogyny in the tech
industry and all this stuff i'm a woman
in tech i have no problem everything's
great and lo and behold two years later
when it's shown to be a profitable
business model she is literally on
twitter saying i'm an oppressed woman in
tech i need your money you know give me
money every month through patreon and
also and it the the it just the complete
polar opposite of what she was saying
before and it's like really so either
the industry has become massively sexist
overnight right you found a way to
profit you know and so so this is sort
of something we could find with any
movement so i don't think i don't think
you're saying this but that this isn't
specific to feminism any movement's
gonna have its people who are doing it
with the right intentions it's gonna
have the people that are being guilted
into it it's gonna have the people that
are being tricked into it it's gonna
have the people that can profit from it
all every single movement and you're
just using feminism as one example i
don't want people to say well you see
he's he's trying to muck up what
feminism is or something to that effect
yeah no no no no it's you're right this
this is and again it's not necessarily
feminism because feminism is just a
subsection of the social justice
movement you know you've got um they
they call it intersectionalism which is
um like there's a reason bell hooks
describes it as the white supremacist
capitalist patriarchy and that's a
surprising
you are you are a supporter of the white
supremacist capitalist patriarchy dave
yeah
in fact i actively propagate i'm a
terrible person but uh but basically
what this encompasses is uh the dynamics
between black people and white people
and the white supremacy uh the
capitalism is the poor and the rich and
the patriarchy being men and women um i
think they probably have terms for gay
and straight and trans and cis but i'm
not familiar with them off top of my
head but but this is this is the point
it's um
they have this toolbox of terms and they
have a big academic backing all of this
comes from academia all of it you know
this has all been and people think oh
this is coming from tumblr it's like no
tumblr is the outgrowth of this cancer
you know
this is it coming to the surface in
popular culture this all comes from sort
of you know the brightly lit halls of
academia where they they start with a
premise they confirm their biases they
peer review their own papers between
feminists and then they carry on
building from that until they've got to
the point where they will and like i
said the redefinition of things the
reason the reason regressives are so
dangerous is
of course as you said with every
movement you're going to get people who
are profiteering you need people doing
it for their own selfish reasons
but i can't think of any movement that
legitimately
has an excuse
to
be malevolent to people
for any good reason you know almost
every single one you like the christians
will love you love your neighbor as
yourself you know and like for for
individualists you know individual
rights and representative democracy
everyone gets to be treated in a
universal manner you know the
brotherhood of man all that sort of
thing whereas these people have
something different they actually have
and i
i can't remember which feminist it is
that i'm quoting when they say this i
think it's andrea dwarkin when they say
that women have the right to hate their
oppressors
now this is
for me a particularly scary aspect of it
and it goes it goes entirely for like
the black lives matter movement
who all subscribe to this kind of
ideology it's the
it's the way of legitimizing hatred for
people based on what is perceived to be
social advantages so if they say well
you're a white man therefore you have
social advantages therefore it's not bad
for me to hate you you know i can i can
say all sorts of things to you and it's
okay because you have privilege i'm
oppressed you're privileged therefore no
matter what i say to you it doesn't
matter even though in an interpersonal
inter in an interaction if you say some
horrible thing to me i'm hurt by it you
know i'm a regular person like my white
privilege isn't actually a shield from
horrible words and also it it takes the
distinction away from someone from a
male who is doing everything he can to
fight for women's rights inequality and
a man who is against those things if you
just say it's white men or it's just men
and we saw this a great example of this
i think is a couple weeks ago with those
cologne attacks and i saw all these
feminists writing articles and tweeting
saying things are this is it's not a
this isn't a migrant problem this isn't
a religion problem they were doing
everything to get it away from
uh the identity of the specific people
who did this and trying this is a male
problem
this is crazy this is actually crazy
it's insane what what happened in
cologne was something called taharush
gamir which is just arabic for uh group
assault or sexual assault um and it's
something that happens i think the first
instance of it was i think it was
originally recorded in the 50s but i
guess it kind of wasn't something that
really came to the surface until about
2011 in the uh egyptian uh arab spring
where a excuse the ac i think was a cnn
journalist was
basically surrounded by a group of guys
in uh in cairo and then molested and
you know forcibly molested by
you know gangs of men and this this
happened on new year's eve all across
europe it happened in stockholm helsinki
or
attempted to in multiple german cities
and it was you know the the police chief
literally said nothing like this has
ever happened before and so when
feminists say well this is just men we
know that's wrong you know we we know
that's wrong we know that it is probably
tied to retrograde attitudes towards
women coming from the islamic world you
know i'm not saying every muslim or
anything like that but you know you you
can't go to the islamic world and look
around and see how things are and say
that women are treated the same there as
they are here right so so that's a
perfect segue to
uh this feminist and islamist video that
you had mirrored who was the guy that
originally created the video
right um the video was originally done
by a small a small youtuber called
saitan atheist okay so he created this
cartoon video and it's a song and it's
basically a feminist and an islamist
singing together about why
they sort of see the world in the same
way that was the thrust of it and i saw
the video and before all hell broke
loose about it before richard dawkins
retweeted it i i saw it and i thought it
was pretty brilliant it's a great
satirical takedown of this regressive
nonsense now i didn't realize at the
time that apparently the the female
character playing the piano apparently
that was actually based off a real
person right i i didn't know that at the
time so the islamist the the islamist
there's a youtuber called dawa man who
um he runs around proclaiming islamism
you know saying that everyone should bow
to islam and all that sort of thing so
it wasn't you know it wasn't victimizing
anyone in particular these are parodies
of individuals but they're individuals
who have become famous because of their
terrible ideas and attitudes right so
go ahead yeah and i mean i i had i i
would love to say that i wrote it or
something but i didn't i literally
emailed the guy and said look i really
like your channel i want to help promote
you do me a piece of unique content that
i can put on my my channel and link back
to you um and so he sent me this video
and i so i put it up and uh and yeah on
all hell broke loose when richard
dawkins retweeted it so basically all
dawkins did was retweet this
and suddenly his twitter feed blew up
and he was de-platformed from a speaking
event at the necss i think it's the
northeast conference of secular skeptics
skeptics and secularism something close
to that he was de-platformed from it
they and they de-platformed him without
even telling him there wasn't even a
phone call they didn't ask for an
explanation
he then they made a public statement to
virtue signal that's the important thing
they were telling other progressives
look you know we're de-platforming him
because he has done something
transgressive to us you know and we want
to show everyone else we're on
we're at the front saying look you know
this is a terrible thing the irony being
richard dawkins was probably a big draw
for that place you know i mean of course
you know he they might get three or four
hundred people there but richard dawkins
has millions of followers you know
he's he's doing them a favor so the you
know they haven't
they've kind of shot themselves in the
foot and they've just made themselves
look really intolerant because his
original tweet was obviously as a
feminist myself this doesn't apply to
all feminists but there is definitely a
pernicious minority and lo and behold
the pernicious minority rose up and you
know got in his face and it's like okay
well you're just proving the point of
the video right so you're literally
proving the point of the video you're
literally proving
that these two groups for all the wrong
reasons have become
partners
that there's one ideology that that
feminists unfortunately or some degree
of feminist seem to be okay with and
it's the same ideology that would do the
worst to women
yes it's hard it's hard to believe that
we even as i'm saying it i'm thinking
this is completely bonkers it is it
absolutely is bonkers and without
intersectionalism it doesn't make any
sense at all you know but when again
you've got to think in sexually so you
think right white person brown person
then man woman you know and so okay
what the question is what is the most
oppressive thing so a man oppressing a
woman that's quite bad but a white
person oppressing a brown person that's
much worse and therefore now we're
talking about a bunch of brown people
being oppressed by a bunch of white
people and so the fact that men and
women are oppressing each other brown
women are oppressing white women that's
not so important the the important bit
is the skin color above the sex which
i'm genuinely surprised at i thought
feminists would go the other way i
thought that they would be more
concerned about men oppressing women
than brown people being oppressed by
white people but apparently they're not
yeah apparently or not so in your
estimation then knowing the way the
feminist movement has evolved and
obviously i've had christina hoff
summers on the show and i've uh talked
to her about some of this stuff what
would you say is the best if you just
want
true equality for the sexes
you're married to a woman you you like
women you know what i mean you're a
heterosexual guy that likes women right
um what would you say is the best way
for men and for women for anyone that
cares about the ideas of feminism to go
out and act on those ideas
um
i mean honestly i think one of the
problems that feminism has now modern
feminism has is it's run out of dragons
to slay you know i mean men men and
women have complete legal equality i
can't think of it whenever whenever a
feminist is challenging you to say oh
you know the men are oppressing women
ask them what legal rights men have over
women they can't name one there just
aren't any and so we're at the point now
where
i mean
i i don't know what more needs to be
done we seem to be living in quite
stable liberal democracies where
merit matters i mean obviously in
everything it is a lot of a lot of what
it is is who you know rather than what
you know but
merit still matters you know you can't
just hire someone
for their arbitrary characteristics if
they can't do the job i mean no one no
one thinks that so i mean
personally i just think don't don't make
judgments based on race or gender or
you know or transgenderism or you know
or homosexuality or anything like that
the these characteristics that generally
aren't very useful to judge people on i
mean you know you're being a white man
doesn't
in any way inform how good an inferior
you are you know i i i'm i'm not
watching you because you're a white man
i'm watching you because i like the
guests you have on i like what the
questions you ask i like the answers you
get out of them you know
none of that has anything to do with you
being white or male or straight or gay
or anything like this they're completely
pointless and arbitrary characteristics
that don't really apply right so really
all we have to do is just keep hammering
the point home right if we're
for people that want to remove this
identity politics stuff we just have to
keep hammering that until it becomes so
obvious and i do think that's where and
this is where we can sort of pivot to a
little more of the regressive tactics
this is where we can really beat them
they're they're tough to beat because we
know they're going to lie we know
they're going to cheat and misinform
people and all of those things
but we can keep hammering them with is
we want equality for everybody
regardless of borders and nationality
and religion and everything else yeah
the the fundamentals of the fundamental
principles of liberalism are universal
that's
that was the great the great gift of
sort of english liberalism is the
individual rights and universal
principles that you and then wrong you
know we've not always applied these you
know evenly or anything like this
and you know initially they were
exclusively for white heterosexual men
at the very top of the pyramid
but the point is that the principles
obviously lend themselves to cascading
downwards because as soon as you have
some people who are espousing these
principles there is no good reason not
to extend the franchise to everyone
which is why we now have universal
suffrage you know it you can't there's
no justification to not you know the and
all of the justifications given we're
all obviously faulty which is why we're
now at the point where we are
um
so yeah it just basically stay true to
your own principles if you think it's
wrong to judge by race don't judge
people by race it doesn't matter what
what race they are if you think it's
wrong to judge by people by sex don't
judge people by sex you know and and the
all i can say is that these are timeless
principles that will always be relevant
you know there will never be a time
where someone says you know actually it
is because i'm black that i should be
judged you know or it is because i'm a
woman that i should be judged and
it's only because these people have
they've got a lot of good and very
slippery language and techniques to
persuade people that in fact you know
given this context it's right to do this
whereas i'm of the opinion that there is
no context in which it's right to judge
people based on characteristics they
have no control over you know if you
didn't get to choose it it's not a part
of your character it doesn't describe
you as a person it just describes your
body or your you know your physical
characteristics it doesn't describe what
you are like in your character so does
this do you think this also goes to the
feeling part of this because that's sort
of what i'm thinking as you're saying
this that there's there's a feeling that
i think
this regressive ideology is attached to
so for example i can't give you a as you
just said i can't give you an example uh
where systemically in the united states
that women are oppressed meaning that
you know there are now laws protecting
you know equal opportunity laws and
things like that now that doesn't mean
that women don't have a harder time
related to certain things if business
deals for example are being done on golf
courses and less women play golf well
then they're they're going to be
excluded and you could probably think of
many many examples like that but what
that is really more about is is a
feeling not sort of a systemic legal
issue and i think that's where people
that's where people struggle to to
separate these things
yeah absolutely i mean i think like
um uh what's the what's the company that
does the sex toys
and summers
uh and summers is a british company i
think and that uh it sells sex toys it's
it was created by a woman and their
large portion of the company is run by
women they probably don't do their
business deals on golf courses you know
they they probably have i don't know
massage piles or nail salons or
something like so you know i know i'm
stereotypical but they don't go to get
golf courses so i would have to change
my position and perspective and i would
have to go to where the the power is
in that situation and don't worry you're
right you know
there are going to be cases where you
have
um
you know powerful ceos who go golfing
and the way to get into their good
graces would be to go golfing as well um
you know sometimes you've got to make
sacrifices
i i personally hate golfing yeah but if
you wanted to be the ceo of this company
or get you know i want to work my way at
the ladder i would take up golfing you
know it doesn't matter about your gender
it matters about how well you golf you
know yeah so
you know i i'd like to say it's not a
perfect system either but it's better
than the alternative because
one thing that people always forget
about quotas is as soon as you start
discriminating in favor of someone
because of skin color sex ethnicity
whatever you are also discriminating
against people on those very same
categories you know if you say right
we've got a position here we need to
hire a black woman then you are
excluding people on the basis of their
race and sex so i i can't agree with
that i think that's wrong yeah
if i'm sure there are plenty of
incredibly talented black women out
there therefore we don't need to make
artificial
adjustments surely you know and at the
end of the day we if we go down this
road then
where does it end where where is the
eventual logical goal eventually you
come to a planned economy where you
can't you can't just have oh no we we
well you're going to hire by merit but
now you've got you know 10 different
categories you've got to go through you
know how many how many trans people do
you have queer people jam any black
white hispanic you know and so now
you're not talking about how good they
are at their jobs now you're talking
about the just arbitrary characteristics
of these people
and what happens when like if three
people leave what do you do three black
people leave your company and all you
have applying for jobs are white people
what do you do yeah you know
you're in a position where it's it's
ridiculous yeah it's really crazy it's
almost like the the
quest for equality is being played sort
of on an unequal playing field and that
just makes everybody kind of nuts well i
think i think nietzsche really did have
it right when he when he was saying that
um
you know be careful when you're battling
monsters because when you stare long
into the abyss the abyss also stares
into you you know and if you if you
stare along into the sort of regressive
mindset of the world is terribly uneven
it's unequal there are no opportunities
for anyone there's no end
we need to do anything we can to help
them then everything becomes justified
you know
it doesn't matter whose rights you
trample on you're doing it for the
greater good and that's what really
so that's actually a great segue to i
want to talk about a little bit about
their tactics so i think in the in the
45 minutes or so that we've been talking
we've talked a lot about their ideas and
obviously we're not fans of their ideas
but i think there's something more
pernicious going on here with some of
the tactics because i don't think it's a
coincidence that many of the main
players in this regressive left movement
have been exposed to be liars to be
plagiarists to be frauds to
purposely manipulate people's words to
create memes that are knowingly
misquoted all of these things i don't
think that's a coincidence now you may
disagree what with what sargon of akkad
says or what dave rubin says
but i don't think you would find
instances where we maliciously
misrepresented people and i suppose
they're just their argument if you
really got them alone if you could
really get an honest moment out of them
which i don't know you could get but i
suppose their argument would be well the
ends justify the means and that's just
the reverse of how i view the world
yeah now that that is
honest honestly that's exactly what it
is right it's about
it
there
there's a lot to unpack here actually
there's
these people are being primed in
universities to be activists and part of
the priming is to give them a good
feeling about doing this activism you
know it's to make them think that they
can emotionally reward themselves by
saying yeah i argued with a misogynist
on twitter you know therefore are you
oh no i'm not kidding though that
genuinely is i've seen feminists i've
seen you know pictures of feminist
courses where on the wall they have a
big twitter activism is feminism and
stuff like this and it's just like
really that's you know but this is the
thing they're encouraged to be activists
they they're encouraged to emotionally
reward themselves for being activists
and so do you know my theory about never
argue with the twitter egg that's what
i'm gonna put on my tombstone one day
yeah i i haven't heard that that's a
good one because i i
i i care about ideas and not like people
or numbers so i care
when someone with like five followers
says you're wrong on this i've got to
argue the case but i've
wow i might be a little more evolved
than you that's pretty good yeah
definitely um what was i saying
um that at the school is that there
there's this there's an intellectual
incentive or there's a feeling incentive
there's an emotional incentive and um
and basically it's they've got to the
point where they've convinced themselves
that progressives or regressivism is the
only morally legitimate position to hold
and so anyone not holding this position
must be a bad person and that's
everything about progressivism in a
nutshell right there if you aren't a
regressive you are a bad person if you
aren't sacrificing other people's rights
for the rights of
a group that you don't know you've got
no connection to but you have been
emotionally primed to fight for
then you're a bad person and so it's
okay for me to call you all these
terrible labels i mean i you would have
to be pretty damn racist for me to call
you a racist you know it's a bad label
it's a real it's a label with a lot of
weight and yet these people throw around
as if it means nothing you know you know
i i always say that i i think i said
this to you when i was on your show that
my awakening had a lot to do with that
whole ben affleck sam harris thing on
real time and and part of what the
craziness of was with that was that
ben threw out racists so quickly
that i agree with you it would take a
lot it would take a lot there are
obvious racists out there and they
should be called out but if you were
arguing with someone it would take a a
real special person for them to
illuminate that they were racist within
30 seconds
i mean yeah i mean i can only imagine
that they came straight out of the gate
with it or something you know they were
like yeah okay black people should be
don't know shipped off the cotton
plantations or something like okay well
you're a racist then aren't you they're
like well i wouldn't call myself
whatever but um you know
yeah you these things normally hold a
lot of weight and they
and that's the reason they're using the
they use labels as weapons and they do
it for a reason for a couple of reasons
actually the first one obviously to put
you on the back foot as soon as you're
called a racist or a homophobe or a
bigger or whatever
then you're defending yourself you're
not defending your ideas you're not
attacking their ideas you're defending
yourself as a person and that's in
itself a logical fallacy called an ad
hominem you know to attack the person
rather than the ideas and you all find
that they do this a lot so basically
right the answer to this is to just say
in your opinion
at the end of it so they'll say you're a
racist you say well in your opinion
right because they'll say you know
you're a racist you're a sexist you're a
bigot in your opinion you know i'm not
and i know i'm not and nothing that i've
said would make any reasonable people
person think that but you
are not a reasonable person and
therefore you're going to label me as a
racist or a big or whatever and honestly
what you've just given me is your
opinion it's not an objective statement
of fact it's like when they use the word
problematic they'll say oh that's
problematic it's like what can you
explain to me what problematic means
immoral does it mean wrong does it mean
illegal no it means transgressive to
progressivism or feminism and it's
basically the same as sinful in the
catholic church or it's the same as
haram in islam you know it's it's the
this is transgressive to my ideology
it's not there's something wrong and
it's not an objective statement of fact
it's i don't like what you've done right
so that i i love that because it goes to
show that they want a certain
intellectual
uh or ideological purity and that's what
the church would want out of you or or
any sort of authoritarian view would
want an intellectual and ideological
pure not intellectual purely ideological
purity it's usually not that
intellectual right no absolutely they
want an ideological ideological
purity out of you and what that does you
know i'm seeing this right now in our uh
democratic debate last week between
bernie and hillary they were arguing
over who's the bigger progressive and
it's like guys that's not what the fight
should be about it should be about if
you're on the left it should be about
who is standing up for liberal
principles more not who fits this narrow
definition because guess what then all
you do as we've said a zillion times is
you hand the debate over to the right
and
absolutely
they're stewing in their own juices
there as well you say i know i'm the
bigger progressive so look you
you don't need to you don't need to
worry about convincing people about
who's the bigger progressive
progressives are going to vote for you
you know liberals but the people you
want to convince are the swing voters
who aren't died in the you know dying
the more progressives they're the people
who aren't you know who are concerned
about issues or concern about policies
you know who can say about what you're
actually going to do rather than you
know ideological brownie points you know
that and so yeah it's it's just this
little circle joke where they've stewed
in their own ideology for so long they
don't understand how they're being
viewed from the outside and like you
said it's driving people to the right
you know it's absolutely driving people
so then what what do we do because that
is not us right we're the ones we're the
ones that are trying to defend classical
liberalism i'm sure you get tons of
emails and tweets and all that stuff
that i get all the time about i see this
split this has happened i get people
telling me they're afraid and
embarrassed to call themselves on the
left i get other people saying they
won't post things on facebook because
they don't want to get called a racist
so all these things so if there's this
growing group of people which there
absolutely is i have no doubt about it
what what do we do to keep this message
going
okay um okay so the great thing about
what's happening is that the
it's interesting because i mean like i
said you had milo yiannopoulos on your
show he was a he was the only journalist
who was prepared to cover game again
initially and i've grown to become
friends with him and people find it
really odd because he's a conservative
and i'm a liberal and i i just tried to
explain to them that look right we've
come to the point where
it's not really about political
affiliation to left and right it's about
whether we can agree on reality you know
we can interpret this reality and have
our own opinions in any way i'm sure
that he's got a lot of opinions that i
disagree with but we can agree that the
numbers are such the the events are as
follows you know whereas the progressive
left will lie to you they will lie to
themselves like that like we said they
will cherry pick their narrative they'll
choose several data points leave out the
ones that contradict what they've said
and then if you don't agree with their
narrative they consider you persona non
grata you're you're
you're you may as well be you know bill
o'reilly or something like that in their
mind and just to be very clear you're
not just you're not just saying
something for the sake of saying it i
mean i have literally seen this happen
to me just to be very clear i mean this
is exactly what's happened to me which i
now wear is a badge of pride by the way
yes well this is one of the things when
you first introduce people to this and
they don't know anything about it
i i honestly think there is a lot of
they they protect themselves with
audacity
and i mean i i'm a big fan of military
history and audacity is one of those
things that wins many wars because it's
so unexpected and i really think that
the things they do are so audacious that
it's hard to persuade people they're
genuinely doing them because people hear
it and think
i would never do that right do that you
know i wouldn't do it i can't imagine
anyone doing it that's not happening
you're a liar you know and they think
that the person relating the information
is the one telling the lie and so the
progressives i think you know they
really really take up on this and say
well that's because he's a racist he's
sexist and all these things and then the
person that has to experience them
acting as they act to really and i've
had so many people come back to being a
man i thought you were full of nonsense
when uh when i first talked but that was
exactly how they are exactly how they
are and i'm like yeah mate i told you
honestly don't worry about it you know
just no no no harm no foul sort of thing
it's
it happens to everyone because at first
when you first hear it it sounds like
nonsense you know you can't believe
anyone would act this way and yet they
do do you sometimes think that maybe the
best way to beat them at this point is
just to ignore them because i think over
the last six months between what we do
here what you do uh what many other
people are doing especially in the
digital space now and what bill maher
has done a little bit more in the
mainstream there's been they've been
exposed and i think because as you said
they're stewing in their juices now part
of me is just like ah
let's just ignore him and then you know
then there's another piece of me that
says we have to keep on the attack which
do you think would be a better uh i
think ignoring them is a very dangerous
tactic i think
the the problem
the problem with that is that you have
the initiative to them
and you say you know i'm not going to
pay attention excuse me to what you're
doing and therefore whatever it is they
do and you're not really aware of and
suddenly something will come at you that
you're not prepared for i
and also it gives them the ground to
continue propagating their ideological
positions yeah
it gets them you know there's no there's
no resistance and so
i mean it's it on twitter yeah sure you
know maybe maybe there's a lot of
resistance but like
if if you get a group a little
delegation of regressives who come to a
workplace and they say oh we'd like to
talk to you about women's equality you
think oh god go on then you know and and
so your boss might like
you know he's just a good guy he doesn't
know he's just all right okay well i'll
do whatever i can you know and suddenly
these people are now advising the upper
echelons of this company and then they
start enforcing ideological conformity
and then suddenly you're in this
position where i mean this happened to
major game studios it's happened to like
games workshop it's there there are
there are
lots of people who have fallen prey to
the
velvet glove of social justice that
contains within the iron fist yeah but
it's just really well hidden so no i i
don't think we can just i i think we
have to fight them and we have to show
people there is a better alternative
that's the eternal point you've you've
got to provide a better alternative and
universal liberal principles in my
opinion are the highest
alternative there is there isn't
anything better you can't get anything
more fair than normal liberal principles
so
i i honestly think just just pushing
these you know showing people these are
the best way to do things and that this
not only encourages equal treatment of
people under the law or in any kind of
social situation but also
it also pushes people to be the best
that they can be it doesn't encourage
them to be victims it doesn't encourage
them to get you know to be depressed and
to to milk it you know there's no room
for frauds when you come to these sorts
of meritocratic principles people have
to work they have to push themselves and
become better and it's about raising the
human condition rather than dragging it
down which is everything about
regressives yeah well naturally i
believe in what you're saying and that's
why i'm doing what i'm doing so i really
more than anything else i should thank
you because you know there were a couple
key people that helped my awakening and
when i had that conversation with you uh
on your channel it was one of the first
times that i really started talking
about this stuff
so you were definitely a key piece in
that so i appreciate that uh and i
appreciate all the work you do and
everyone
can find out more of sargon's take on
gamergate feminism regressives and
plenty more over on his youtube channel
which is youtube.com sargon of akkad 100
and sargon carl or do you have any other
names that i need to know about uh no i
think that's just the two those are the
big two all right well i appreciate it
and thank you guys for watching and
we'll do it again next week